It's time to update the weather app to
cache the app shell on install, and
clean the old resources from
the cache in the activate event.
Here's what I want you to do.
In your app JS file,
register a new service worker,
but only if server workers
are available in the browser.
Then create an install event
handler in the service worker
that caches the resources required for
the app shell.
Next, create an active event
handler in the service worker
that removes old
resources from the cache.
Next, create a fetch event handler
in the service worker that attempts
to return content from the cache but
falls back to the network
if it's not available.
When you've completed this step,
your app should now cache its app
show on first load and then for
subsequent loads return all of the app
shell resources from the cache.
If one of the resources change, the
cache should update on the next reload.
Be sure to compare your app to
the link in the instructor notes below
to make sure it works exactly the same.
And don't forget to try your
app in multiple browsers.